yeah again I mean I have found that in
recent years I have gotten drawn to what
is known in political sciences pluralism
which is a sort of strain and political
thinking that tends to take a much more
benign view of lobbies than the most
journalists take so I am the premise
behind the horror / lobbyists is that
there's something called the public
interest that would emerge naturally if
there were no lobbyists or if there were
only good lobbyists and not bad
lobbyists or if there were only they
were lobbyists but lobbyists without a
lot of cash to throw around etc and I'm
very very suspicious of the idea of the
public interest because it's it's kind
of one of the oldest problems in
politics and government who gets to
decide you know I think the term the
public interest is inherently elitist
because people just don't agree about
what it is and and so I like the idea of
Democrat of a democracies politics as
being a kind of market system where
everybody has a different take on what
the good is and they sort of fight it
out in in the political arena now some
of these groups are going to be more
organized than others politics favors
the organized and and as you know all
these groups are going to lobby I don't
necessarily think that a so-called
public interest group lobby is is more
legitimate than Allah be like in
no sugar farmers or a labor union or a
traditional economic base lobby in other
words I'm uncomfortable the idea that
they're good guy lobbies and bad guy
lobbies I guess I'd agree that you know
bribery should be illegal in politics
and I like I think information is good
and under that flag campaign finance
reform to the extent that involves
disclosure is a very good idea but I
just don't I think the idea that you can
sort of extra pay k street from American
politics is is an illusion and you might
not even want that because it's very
hard to define k street in a sense is
the group that you're if you're in a
group that is opposed to you know female
genital mutilation in Africa are you K
Street are you a lobbyist you know or
are you are you a reformer crusading for
the public interest
lobbying isn't a Coke and Pepsi system
because the country is so complicated
there's so many groups that you can't
say these two groups predominate there's
a tremendous amount of catan there isn't
such a thing as the business community
for example there isn't such a thing as
the labor community because they have
tremendous internal dissension so it's
really a question of do some and but I
don't accept you know there's a
wonderful book called the the process of
government published a hundred years ago
almost 19 08 by Arthur Bentley a former
journalist turned political scientist
and he what the term public interest
group wasn't around then but he calls
these groups of quote-unquote talk
groups which is a little mean but but
I'm very uncomfortable with the idea
that that a group that you know to use
my example opposes FGM in Africa exists
on a higher moral plane than a group
that fights for higher wages for itself
for example I don't understand why that
is necessarily so and you could say that
this group of wonderful people fighting
against FGM in Africa are actually
trying to impose their will on people
half a world away who may not sign on to
the idea that this is in their interest
so the only real question is is this is
a system designed to create you know
there's it's like antitrust there's a
sort of this is a market and so markets
I think shouldn't be totally unregulated
you want to create conditions inside
markets where you know one player and
one category of players doesn't have an
unfair advantage so the real question is
not can we get rid of lobbying but have
we got is there a problem in the system
where one group has disproportionate
advantage over others and and then if so
what should we do better one type of
group but that's a
more fine-grain way of saying it than
just saying yes these lobbyists are off
we must get rid of them